while it might look like it's nothing
but glitz and glamour a ton of unseen
work goes into making television for
actors it can lead to even more labor
especially if they share a hand in
writing producing or directing while
acting can be a difficult and demanding
job actors are paid massive amounts of
money to make up for it still even among
the wealthiest actors in Hollywood these
television celebrities take the cake
here are TV stars who took home
shockingly huge paychecks like all
sitcoms The Big Bang Theory depends on a
consistent likable cast it was almost no
surprise when the central trio kaley
cuoco Johnny Galecki and Jim Parsons
were able to negotiate a salary bump to
$1,000,000 each per episode before
season 10 the surprise is that they
actually gave some of it back as they
later took a $100,000 pay cut to help
their fellow cast members are in their
own sizeable bump nice when it comes to
well paid sitcom actors you can't ignore
the cast of friends who managed to
capture audience's hearts and
NBCUniversal x' wallet all at once while
the cast might have gone their separate
ways after the show ended they banded
together for equal pay checks in the
final seasons
[Laughter]
friends it turns out you can have both
the popularity of the show meant the
cast had a massive amount of bargaining
power and the six stars took advantage
by entering into a joint negotiation for
a cool $1,000,000 each per episode for
seasons 9 and 10 for the Netflix
produced continuation of Gilmore Girls
Alexis Bledel and Lauren Graham both
managed to score an impressive $750,000
per episode that's enough money to buy
delivery food for the rest of their
lives the whole point of getting
everything within delivery distance is
so we can judge the quality of food
speed of service cuteness of delivery
guys on a scale of one to ten we cannot
work for memory on this as Game of
Thrones has killed off most of its cast
it's become a lot clearer which
characters are the real protagonists in
the show as you might expect this
revelation led to some powerful
bargaining chips for these actors
Variety reported in 2016 that Kit
Harington Lena Headey Peter Dinklage
Emilia Clarke and Nikolaj coster-waldau
all managed to grab a cool 500 thousand
dollars per episode of course you've
also heard the phrase Lannister always
pays his debts and it seems like HBO
does too doctors tend to be well-paid
but playing a doctor on television is
even more lucrative Ellen Pompeo of
Grey's Anatomy receives 575 thousand
dollars per episode of the long-running
medical drama the show is still
incredibly successful after over a dozen
seasons but what did Pompeo do to
deserve such a high pay check
Pompeyo told The Hollywood Reporter the
truth is anybody can be good on a show
season 1 & 2 can you be good 14 years
later now that's a skill he might be
more well known as a film star but
Dwayne the rock Johnson has been making
a pretty tidy sum of money as a
television star to Johnson stars in the
HBO show ballers which follows a
financial manager negotiating deals for
his slightly less massive clients for
his part in the show Johnson earned a
pool six hundred fifty thousand dollars
per episode enough to vault him onto
this list even without including his
movie star paychecks in between episodes
the big little lies stars are drawing
some very big paychecks in advance of
the award-winning HBO hit second season
leads Reese Witherspoon and Nicole
Kidman negotiated to earn over 1 million
dollars per episode that's the benefit
of being a list movie stars appearing in
a pristine
drama combining a genial personality and
a deep roster of celebrity friends Ellen
DeGeneres has built a full-blown
multimedia Empire in 2017 her estimated
annual income reached 50 million dollars
and that was calculated before the
premiere of her new show game of games
at this rate DeGeneres could probably
give out her own money on her game show
and still come out ahead what's left to
say about Oprah that her massive media
empire hasn't said already her
syndicated television show made her
Millions
along with all the numerous sponsorships
and merchandising deals that came from
listing her favorite things in fact
she's so successful at media
entrepreneurship it's difficult to find
out what she made strictly from her
television series we do know that in
2011 which included the final season of
The Oprah Winfrey Show she took home an
estimated 290 million dollars and that
was reportedly a major pay cut from the
previous year her total wealth is worth
more than the GDP of some countries and
she's the only billionaire on this list
[Applause]
according to the Washington Post Judge
Judy star Judith Sheindlin makes a
mind-boggling 47 million dollars for
only 52 days of work meaning that she
makes almost 1 million dollars a day
wondering about the secret to her
success it's apparently an absolute
ruthless negotiating tactic of refusing
to negotiate Judy told The Hollywood
Reporter we sit across the table and I
hand him the envelope and I say don't
read it now let's have a nice dinner
call me tomorrow you want it fine
otherwise I'll produce it myself
that's the negotiation
[Music]